Hey Thoughty2 here.
The year is 1902, twelve young men at the
peak of their physical fitness and the peak
of their careers are sat round a table, dressed
in their finest evening-wear.
Silver cutlery and crisp white linen adorn
the table.
They are served only the highest quality food,
cooked with the expertise of a top chef and
a top toxicologist.
Because every mouthful of this delicious food
has been laced with poison.
From formaldehyde in the mashed potato to
borax in the lamb shank.
Every tasty meal is laden with chemicals intended
to kill humans.
But these men were very aware what they were
eating and did so willingly.
For they were the Poison Squad.
The willing participants of this macabre squad
were mostly medical students or employees
of the Bureau of Chemistry.
For five years the men sat down to a nightly
meal prepared by a government-run kitchen.
They would be fed a range of toxic and poisonous
substances, mixed up and hidden within their
meals.
Each member of the squad was monitored meticulously
at all times to observe the effects.
If a member started to get seriously ill from
a poison their dose would be reduced.
The poison squad was a daring new experiment
by chemist Dr. Harvey Wiley.
Its goal was to identify harmful substances
that were making their way into our food so
food labelling could be improved.
You see, up until this experiment, manufacturers
would chuck any old substance into food products
to achieve the desired effects, such as strychnine
in Bitter Beer and arsenic in children's sweets.
Something needed to be done and this daring
experiment played a large part in the creation
of the Food and Drug Administration.
The Year the experiment ended the Pure Food
and Drug act of 1906 was passed in the US.
Sadly one member of the poison squad died
due to his organs eventually shutting down
from all the ingested poison.
Thankfully we've come a long way from having
to eat poisons to test our food products.
Even though practically everything we eat
today is safe, we all know at least one "picky
eater", that friend who will eat nothing but
fried chicken and then of course there's that
guy you know who will eat absolutely anything,
from olives to deep-fried insects.
Maybe the picky eater is you?
But what separates these two people, we're
all born with the same equipment for tasting
food so why do certain foods provoke reactions
of disgust, even hate, in some people?
There's one particular animal that knows all
too well about picky eating, the rat.
Rats are one of nature's pickiest animals,
for one good reason, they don't possess the
ability to vomit.
If a rat ingests something toxic and gets
food poisoning, it has no mechanism to rid
the spoiled food from its body, which can
often be fatal.
Rats have therefore evolved to be extremely
suspicious of new foods and will do something
called "sampling" when they come across new
food.
Rats will taste a tiny bit of the food to
see if it will make them sick, if not then
it will return later and gobble the whole
lot.
Fortunately, we humans have various mechanisms
to protect ourselves against food poisoning
and we can often recover from a dodgy meal
without medical assistance.
But just like the rat our pickiness about
certain foods comes from our evolutionary
past.
Scientists have studied why some people are
averse to some foods and they suspect it has
to do with our time spent as hunter gatherers.
Long before and even for many hundreds of
thousands of years after, our hominid ancestors
invented the spear and other hunting tools,
we had to forage to survive.
Without farming and because hunting meat was
unpredictable, our ancestors had to live off
foraged nuts, seeds, berries and vegetation
to survive.
But many berries, nuts and plants contain
deadly poisons that would incapacitate or
kill humans if ingested.
So evolution devised a clever way for our
ancestors to identify which foods might be
toxic.
We developed tastebuds, thousands of tiny
receptors on our tongue that detect five elements
of taste: sour, salty, sweet, umami and most
importantly, bitter.
The toxic substances and poisons found in
certain wild berries, nuts and plants contain
lots of bitter tasting compounds.
So if our ancestors put something in their
mouth that tasted bitter there was a chance
it could be poisonous.
This was an intelligent and highly effective
system but of course today, we no longer need
to detect poisons in our food.
Today food production is highly regulated
in all developed countries, we can simply
read the packaging to find out exactly what's
in our food.
But a distaste for bitter foods is still embedded
deep within our DNA.
We generally find bitterness unpleasant.
But of course this is not a universal rule
for everyone.
Some people hate the bitter taste of broccoli,
but many others love it.
Research has found it all has to do with our
DNA.
When it comes to bitterness there are two
types of genes, taster genes and non-tasters.
The taster gene has been passed down from
our hominid ancestors, whereas those with
the non-taster gene, which is a relatively
recent mutation within the gene-pool, don't
taste the bitterness in vegetables such as
broccoli and sprouts.
But of course everyone gets two of these genes,
one from each parent.
If you get two non-taster genes, one from
each parent, then congratulations, you are
super lucky because you can't taste the bitterness
in vegetables and other bitter foods.
But if, on the other hand you got two taster
genes from your parents, then you're most
likely a very picky eater, especially when
it comes to your greens, because not only
can you taste bitterness but you're extremely
sensitive to it; to you foods such as broccoli
will taste almost inedibly bitter, your body
will be repulsed the second it touches your
tongue.
So if you know someone who is picky about
their veg, maybe cut them some slack, because
it's not actually their fault, it's in their
DNA.
You may be wondering what happens if you get
one gene from each parent, a non taster and
a taster gene.
Researchers have found that such people may
not like the taste of bitter foods when they're
younger but through repeatedly trying such
foods they can actually learn to like them
as they grow older, and potentially even appreciate
bitter flavours.
This is why certain foods that you hated when
you were younger are no longer a problem for
you when you hit your twenties or thirties.
So that covers the vast majority of people's
food choices.
But what about the extremely picky eaters,
those individuals that categorically will
not eat anything but an extremely limited
selection of food.
You know, that person who will ONLY eat cereal
and nothing else or that person who won't
eat anything that casts a shadow, oh wait,
that's vegans.
In such individuals the cause is more than
genetics and we start to enter the realm of
psychology.
Doctors believe they have diagnosed such extreme
fussy eaters and it turns out they have a
genuine eating disorder.
It's called Food Neophobia.
We all experience neophobia to some extent.
It's simply the fear or apprehension of trying
new or unfamiliar foods, but true neophobics
take that fear to a whole new level, where
even the thought of eating anything except
what they're used to, make's them feel nauseous.
It's believed that neophobia has its roots
in genetics, and having certain genes can
increase a person's neophobic tendencies.
However to reach a high level of neophobia,
where a person will outright refuse to eat
anything new, even something that many other
would find desirable, such as pizza, there
needs to be an added psychosocial factor on
top of their genetics.
When growing up, if children don't experience
their parents eating a wide variety of foods
or never trying new foods, they are much more
likely to develop neophobia.
And of course, parents who are rather unadventurous
with their culinary choices are far more likely
to give their children uninspired and similar
foods, night after night, which only makes
the likelihood of the child developing neophobia
far, far worse.
The biggest problem with neophobia is that
once it sets its claws into a child it's extremely
hard to break its hold and in the vast majority
of cases it continues into adulthood.
So how do we prevent neophobia from developing
in the first place?
Well the answer lies to the east, in a magical
and bizarre place called Japan.
I've talked previously about how Japan is
the healthiest country in the world, with
the highest life expectancy.
It's long been thought that how we are taught
to eat as a child stays with us our whole
lives and hugely affects our eating habits
as an adult, for better or for worse.
Japanese culture has taken this to the extreme
and Japanese children eat a far more varied
and healthier diet than kids in every other
country, which could explain why they have
such long life expectancies.
Japanese children have the lowest childhood
obesity rates in the developed world and it's
easy to see why.
Snacking between meals is unheard of and Japanese
kids are strongly encouraged to never snack,
at least until after they've eaten.
Japanese children eat exactly what their parents
eat, which gets them use to a wide variety
of foods and cuisines from an early age.
There's no microwave chicken nuggets for the
kids and then a different meal for the parents
as is common in many western homes.
But this approach to food doesn't stop outside
of the home.
Japanese school dinners are often praised
as being the highest quality and healthiest
of any country.
Every meal is cooked from scratch, every morning
in the school kitchen.
Quality ingredients are sourced from local
farms.
A typical Japanese school dinner consists
of a few different elements that vary each
day, but it usually includes tofu and vegetables
in miso soup, rice with seaweed and fish or
meat with even more vegetables.
If a kid doesn't like that meal, then tough,
because there is only ever one option each
day.
There is no choice at meal times for Japanese
school children; whatever is cooked that day
is what they will eat.
Because let's face it, there's no point in
offering a healthy option if 99% of school
kids are going to instead opt for pizza and
chips.
But having no other choice works so well in
Japan because there are practically no picky
eaters, eating disorders such as neophobia
are pretty much non-existent in Japan.
And maybe that's due to their food culture
within the home and at school.
So when it comes to eating habits maybe we
should all try to be a little more Japanese.
Would that be such a bad thing, I mean, they
have ramen; everybody likes ramen.
Thanks for watching.
I'm really excited to present this limited
edition Thoughty2 t-shirt.
I've made this exclusively for fans and it
will only be available for the next two weeks,
then it's gone forever.
There's a link in this video's description
to get hold of yours.
Remember this is a limited time flash sale
so click the link below to buy yours now.
Also, I'd love to hear your feedback because
I'm excited to create more amazing products
for fans in the future.